hello everyone and a special welcome to
all you georgie's out there this is
versus the hit tv sensation that
millions of people watch every week
usually as background noise while
they're doing everyday chores like
vacuuming cleaning dishes or
investigating mysterious fogs that have
overtaken their town the last one might
seem a little far-fetched but it's right
in the fairway for talking about boston
red sox season ticket holder stephen
king how can i help you when he's not
singing take me out to the ball game
he's probably making us shriek with
terror as another one of his classic
horror stories unfolds with each turn of
the page luckily for folks who don't
care for the dewey decimal system they
now offer king masterpieces as
convenient tv shows perfect for anyone
who needs to get that book report done
in a timely manner
today on the show i your fearless host
mark ellis who am i kidding i saw the
shining with the guy from wings and i
didn't sleep for a month we'll set out
to determine once and for all what is
the greatest television accomplishment
of stephen king's illustrious career he
writes best-selling novels and sometimes
they get turned into big time theatrical
releases but more often than not the
slow burn of the miniseries on the small
screen is the perfect metronome with
which to weave another spellbinding king
tale every one of the tv shows based on
his stories could be in contention today
jesus [ __ ] christ which means i will
now run down the contenders after taking
a deep breath that could be my last
all right now i need one more deep
breath here we go golden years the
shining kingdom hospital nightmares and
dream skates bag of bones the outsider
11 22 63 mr mercedes storm of the
century castle rock the dead zone salem
slot haven chapel wait the stand it rose
red under the dome the mist salem's lot
again the langley ears slicey story the
stand in the tommy knockers
oh all right come on that was impressive
right only took me eight takes and then
a few more after that here's how we'll
determine a winner round one tomato
meter slash audience score round two
villains round three iconic moments
round four cultural legacy and then
we'll do a wild card round that could
involve anything from stolen mercedes to
dangerous stalkers to deadly plagues
really do we have to include the stand
it's compelling stuff but you know after
the last few years hey i guess that's
what makes tv truly terrifying it feels
like it could happen to us maybe before
another scary pandemic hits we build a
nice dome over the town that's going to
keep nah that's not a good idea either
there's just no winning in stephen king
worlds except of course for us the
audience
that almost sounded convincing king has
been a consistent force in entertainment
for decades and remains unrivaled as the
horror master of the modern era so grab
your balloons and your wooden stakes
it's time for a good old-fashioned scary
small screen shin dig let's get it on
holy old
jesus
round one tomato meter slash audience
score i'd love to include a round in
today's contest that focuses on which
king property generated the highest
ratings upon airing or which streaming
show garnered the most eyeballs week to
week but unfortunately them nielsen
boxes weren't installed in any castle
rock homes and the data provided by some
streaming networks is less reliable than
a stephen king character so we'll start
out the contest with the reaction
metrics known as the tomato meter and
the audience score thanks very much sir
how did critics and the general populous
feel about a given program after they
watched it was it time well spent or
would you rather have been gabbing with
a ghost bartender instead
absolutely not one might think that more
recent releases would have the advantage
as they saw the light of day when we
already had these measurement scales in
place and one would be wrong sir wrong
no we're to peabody and sherman our way
all the way back to 1979 when salem's
lot hit the airwaves and no this is not
the film version starring nfl fan rob
lowe we're talking to toby hooper
directed treatise starring david soul
bonnie bedelia and fred willard it sets
the bar high out of the gate clocking in
with an 89 on the tomato meter that's a
score bested only by mr mercedes and the
outsider both of which earned a 91
percent on the tm castle rock is also
competitive here notching an 88 followed
closely by nightmares and dreamscapes at
86 percent storm of the century at 83
percent and 82
goes to 11 22 63 where james franco goes
back in time to stop a presidential
assassination a much more noble cause
than going back in time to make sure
your parents hook up at a dance
you're my mum
here's exhibit number three million and
why stephen king is the goat of all of
his tv projects only six are rotten on
the tomato meter that low bar it's set
by the tommyknockers at 30 which given
the fact that all these are horror-based
that's a pretty good number i know a lot
of leprechauns and killer dolls that
would murder for 30
and they have i hate you
storm of the century based on a king's
screenplay and castle rock based on his
stories both hold strong with audiences
as well century checks in with an 86 on
the audience score while rock cashes in
at 79 percent and the cream is starting
to rise to the top unfortunately for
edward vlad nosferatu blade and all the
other vampires out there salem's lot
falls considerably on this side of
things down to 64
still fresh but not as well preserved
look at me
yeah most of these shows improve their
standing once the audience gets to weigh
in tommy knockers gets all the way up to
39
11 22 63 vaults up to 88 and the award
for most improved goes to
rose red based on a king screenplay the
2002 project is just 40 on the tomato
meter but elevates to 80 with the
audience that's like man on fire level
improvement right there what is going on
only storm of the century and 11 22 63
can brag about being so fresh on both
measurements that they're at least 80
percent on each side but remember the
outsider ben mendelsohn cynthia revo a
really creepy thing in the woods its
audience scores 83 and when we pronounce
that husband and wife with its tomato
patch total of 91 that averages out to
87
the highest on the board for any king tv
entry 11 22 63 gives a great battle but
only one show can take the point here
and it goes to home box office down goes
amazon down goes amazon you still got
four rounds relax the outsider is now
the only member of the in crowd and goes
up one to nothing on the field no
round two villains well if it's bad guys
murderous demons or otherworldly forces
you enjoy you've come to the right place
on the right day it's really all we get
day in and day out around here that
being stephen king's imagination and
last round's winner the outsider makes a
compelling case here too simply because
what the hell is that thing that can
sort of look like humans we know tossing
the real people into a world of
suspicion it's the show that makes me
glad i stopped building forts in the
woods long before it came along are you
[ __ ] kidding me but the shining is a
legacy thanks in large part due to the
slow unraveling of jack torrance's mind
all work and no video game breaks make
him a dull boy indeed
in the 1997 version stephen weber steps
into the roomy boots of jack nicholson
but this time he was armed with king
himself overseeing things stephen king
famously didn't like stanley kubrick's
big screen treatment almost two decades
earlier so now he wanted to make sure
his vision was brought to life and death
especially if you're crashing in room
237 and if any of you feel sorry for
jack and feel like he's not a villain
until he's completely lost his mind
towards the end king feels differently
describing this torrance as a character
not with an arc but a flat line he's
crazy from the jump said the legendary
author
point
wrong
some 24 years later king returned to
adapt his own work into a show this time
with lizzi's story on apple tv julianne
moore is a grieving widow after losing
her writer husband played by clive owen
but as the real writer probably knows
all too well with authorial success
comes super fans some of them a little
demented where did you get it
she gave it to me
easy as pie dane dehaan is our creep
here and he makes an excellent case for
winning this round with his terrifying
advances towards more attempting to
secure her hubby's unpublished
manuscripts so we have dehan and weber
as contenders here but also entering the
ring is another wings cast member no
it's not crystal bernard or thomas
hayden church or tony shalhoub man that
show really was the gift that kept on
giving it's tim daly starring in storm
of the century he's actually the
protagonist here because he's tim
freaking daily but when a stranger
shrouded a mystery named andre shows up
literal hell breaks loose colin fiore is
note perfect as the baddie who utters
menacing lines like give me what i want
and i'll go away will you though really
i'm not buying it we'll talk
points also go to mr mercedes and craig
toomey from the languers played by you
guessed it perfect strangers legend
bronson pinchot but our final real
combatant in this most villainous round
is none other than the clown who loves
the circus balloons and murdering
younglings tim curry is petty wise in
1990s small screen it
here i am weezy we first meet ronald
mcdonald's cousin as he's about to feast
upon a poor little girl there's no
sewers yet he's going full michael myers
and is lurking behind a clothesline
until it's bite o'clock all of these
villains have scares to spare but more
so than any other king evil doer
pennywise just keep sticking around
[Laughter]
even when he's dormant during his
extended hibernation period he can
really take a hell of a nap the threat
of a return haunts his victims who
managed to survive his last outing in a
case of life imitating art it was almost
right on pennywise's return clock that
the big screen it appeared 27 years
after the tv version aired bill
skarsgard makes for one horrific circus
freak but staying with me for my entire
existence has been tim curry and his
portrayal of everyone's least favorite
birthday party performer for terrorizing
our dreams then now and forever
pennywise gets the w in round two and it
gets on the board just when you thought
it was safe to go back to the laundry
line
round three iconic moments
and as is now tradition for this episode
only it has the honor of going first in
this next phase which will be won by the
show that has given us the most
bone-chilling fright suspenseful
sequences and maybe a possible laugh
just to break up the tension
i mean come on john freaking ritter is
in the 1990 version of it so we gotta
get some yucks right kiss me fat boy ah
sadly not many in lieu of two attractive
roommates and zany neighbors on three's
company here we get a gaggle of
childhood friends all bonded together by
two things being relative outcasts
amongst their peers and that whole
killer clown thing at least when they
come from space they give us a warning
one of the best moments in it is seeing
the kids as adults and that moment when
they break the news to each other that
p-dog is back for one more run at terror
it doesn't matter what's going on in
their lives be it writing relationship
trauma success descending into
alcoholism once each individual adult
here's what's going on back in derry all
that childhood horror comes rushing back
to the forefront pennywise also has some
sweet kills
[Music]
he brings his a game when it comes to
tricking a pint-sized snack into coming
a little too close and is particularly
haunting the way he'll play on one's
individual past to trick them clowns
don't trust him i am your worst dream
come true meanwhile in salem's lot
vampires are the baddie du jour and
director toby hooper came up with a
number of inventive ways to give them an
extra air of mystique and menace they
levitate in a foggy mist and in the next
decade the lost boys would employ a
similar tactic kurt barlow in a nod to
nosferatu has makeup effects that were
revolutionary for the time so much so
that artist jack young and ben lane were
nominated for an emmy face the master
look at me open the window for fans of
the 79 version those phrases alone will
conjure some of the coolest vampire
moments we've ever seen throw away the
cross
face the master
the outsider plays much more like a slow
burn as we gradually start to realize
what is really affecting this town is
something that isn't easily explained a
climax deep underneath the woods in
abandoned mines pays off and the show
did such an excellent job of leaving us
on the edge of our seats by the end of
every hour sunday nights could not
arrive soon enough the shared dna
between that and mr mercedes is the
character of holly gibney in mr mercedes
it's the tale and ensuing investigation
of a psycho who drives a stolen car into
a crowd that's pretty haunting and
brendan gleason and harry treadway are
also both so good on the show but back
in the day almost 19 million people took
in the stand in 1994 and one of the
reasons most stuck around is that
incredible opening scene setting us up
for these two camps that ultimately will
wage a civil war between good and evil
three years later we'd be blessed uh is
that a weird word to use given our
subject matter today with the shining
and it has its share of moments we
expect like a dad going cray-cray or a
really um dirty girl in the bathtub but
it's also got whacked out stuff like a
fire hose that's hungry and a floating
teenager dispelling some advice to young
danny torrance unlike the shining in
which most of us came in with some level
of expectation thanks to the movie uh
don't tell stephen i really like the
film have you ever thought for a single
solitary moment about my
responsibilities to my employers storm
of the century was a fresh blizzard of
thrills and chills chock full of great
moments that continue to build
throughout the four hour plus run time
setting the tone is the creepy rhyme
schemes of this mysterious stranger with
a bloody cane far from a simple walking
aid it adds more to the tail than anyone
in town could have bargained for we're
also treated to grand spectacle pieces
such as when an axe through a door shows
all hell breaking loose on the other
side every town has its secrets and
andre is hell-bent on exploiting every
last one of them and maybe taking one of
their kids as a booby prize hey if
you're gonna look like emperor palpatine
you might as well play the part no
fittingly it originally aired on
valentine's day 1999. the show was
broken into three parts and featured a
satisfying ending so much so the king
deemed it his absolute favorite out of
all his tv achievements up to that time
so who are we to disagree look i love 11
22 63 and the fish out of water or time
sequences that we get but storm of the
century is captivating it's got a
well-paced narrative and it plays out
like a long iconic moment from when we
first see andre's message give me what i
want and i'll go away uh i can't
necessarily do that but i can give you
the point in this round
that help from the century takes round
three and is on the board alongside the
outsider and it
mother nature
round four cultural legacy
and now we look to exactly what have you
done after the tv's been turned off for
the night or you fell asleep and woke up
to see the national anthem close out
your broadcast day followed by a bunch
of snow that entices young kids to climb
through the tv look i know poltergeist
isn't technically stevie king but it
fits the bill for today
[Music]
anywho which show has held up the best
and had the biggest influence on our
culture the world of entertainment our
nightmares that's the series that's
going to take the round and earn a point
here and storm of the century has had
somewhat of a resurgence in the last
couple of years thanks to mike
flanagan's hit netflix show midnight
mass having a climactic sequence that
pays homage to its 1999 godfather or
devil father be not afraid
but let's be real a round like cultural
legacy reaches beyond the show itself
and forms an unholy alliance with the
original source material to lodge itself
in our gray matter so it's safe to
assume that older projects like salem's
lot it and the shining have a leg up in
this round simply because they've been a
part of the zeitgeist for so long and so
far in this round alone i've gotten to
say two geist words poulter zeit dare i
try for beetle geiss hi how are you
the shining plays into everyone's fears
in two key ways you have the whole
family dynamic and the hotel aspect for
families what do you do when the
patriarch starts to go a little nuts and
for travelers how do you handle staying
summer that could be so haunted simply
changing rooms ain't gonna cut it the
1997 series does a brilliant job at
displaying both and it's a bold choice
by king and company to make us not trust
stephen webber's jack sooner than we
started to lose faith in nicholson's
version he didn't let me finish my
sentence i said i'm not gonna hurt you
i'm just gonna bash your brains and the
hotel keeps playing tricks on her mind
occasionally making the viewer feel like
we're losing our grip on reality as well
the stanley kubrick version is clearly
the more referenced just look at steven
spielberg's ready player one which built
a whole entire scene upon the overlook
hotel but the 1997 show may have gotten
inside our heads a little deeper for
salem's lot the job was simple make us
believe that vampires could be
terrorizing a town mission accomplished
and then some
hooper's 1979 iteration paved the way
for loads of vampiric war to follow so
much so that many feel salem's lot
hasn't gotten the credit it deserves in
the history of bloodsucker war there is
a smooth operator dracula type then
there's the evil force phylum less
concerned with being a dashing romantic
and more like being a sick plague
invading an unsuspecting populace that's
where salem's lot butters its bread as
barlow's arrival to town signals an
alarming rise in folks going missing
we've seen this time and time again in
everything from the big screen the lost
boys to both versions of buffy the
vampire slayer am i the only one who
remembers it was a movie first it's it's
good i love it
yes
and with lineage that harkens all the
way back to nosferatu salem's lot has
cemented a high place within the
hollywood vampire war that's not to be
confused with the hollywood vampires
club of the 1970s which featured such
members as alice cooper harry nelson and
john lennon they weren't biting next
they were just drinking look it up good
stories all right back to salem's plot
if vampires have been amongst the
scariest antagonists in art history
clowns have really stepped on the gas
pedal the last few decades
remember they used to be fun just
running around the circus tying balloons
into animals at birthday parties then
they broke bad real bad
enter pennywise the clown who will show
up once every few decades to feast on
the youngins in derry maine the 1990 tv
production plays out like a
coming-of-age drama that's peppered with
don't talk to strangers psa messaging
tim curry's pennywise is an unhinged
nightmare of a villain one wonders why
you'd name a rock band after him but
he's also a metaphor for trauma gone
untreated when us adults prefer to bury
the dark remnants of our past deep
inside rather than deal with them
beverly marsh might be the most obvious
example of this but every kid in the
losers club wrestles with their demons
in some way oh and they also have to
figure out how to send a clown back to
hell all in a day's work this is battery
acid you slime
but the big difference between salem's
lot and fellow front runners like it and
the shining is that i could argue the
salem's lot big screen version hampered
its impact somewhat that movie is just
not good
1980's the shining and 2017's it joined
king's source material and adding to our
nightmares 1979's salem's lot had to do
all the heavy lifting and despite a
decent 2004 reimagining with rucker
hower who also played a vampire in the
movie buffy the vampire slayer it's the
og small screen telling that has
remained a force in sinister
storytelling to this very day all three
projects will remain cornerstones of
stephen king's legacy but if i had to
pick one project that carried the most
influence without the aid of companion
big screen movies my choice is salem's
lot again i know it's a movie but it's
terrible don't even look at it that's my
decision i'll probably change my mind
tomorrow
if i wake up tomorrow salem's like gets
the point i don't always take the word
of people i just met as gospel and now
it's time for the wild card round battle
of the network stars i don't think the
stork had placed me on earth yet when
battle of the network stars was actually
airing but the name fits like a glove
here because the wild card round is
gonna pit the previous four winners
against one another in a winner take all
contest as we ask a simple question what
show of the four previous round winners
is indeed the scariest i had a bunch of
options for the wild card round because
let's say something like 11 22 63 made
it that's not fair to say it's scary as
it or salem's lot but then on the other
hand being stuck back in time tracking
lee harvey oswald doesn't exactly sound
like a day at the beach either but alas
here we go with the four nominees for
scariest stephen king show for all the
marbles it the outsider salem's lot and
the shining huge rounds of applause are
due for worthy contenders like mr
mercedes and honorable mentions like
storm of the century but they didn't
quite cut the mustard on the watermelon
to make it into the final four and now i
just want to see pennywise on a
basketball court dunking on vampires
stephen king if you're watching this i
know you're a sports guy let's have that
crossover happen nah to determine which
show is indeed the most terrifying we
need to examine why each program is so
good at what it does best starting with
you it
the frights come from all sorts of
directions for these poor kids in fact
at the outset a clown is the least of
their concerns there's some pretty awful
parenting in the mix others coming from
families that are going through tough
times you got your disappearing siblings
boys at school they live in a town where
apparently the only fun thing to do is
build a dam it's a struggle and now that
i think about how boring darry was i'd
jump at the chance if a clown offered me
a balloon didn't work out for georgie
though and after he goes missing his
older brother is never the same for
salem's lot the answer to what's scary
about it seems simple have you seen a
vampire they hunt at night and they suck
blood case closed to quote the clump
patriarch and the naughty professor
but even more frightening is the mood
and atmosphere that takes over the town
once the lead vamp comes to roost under
the guise of dealing antiques dudes
turning into bats is creepy a town
turned against itself in sort of a civil
war is a recurring theme in king works
like the mist and under the dome and it
works brilliantly for salem's lot in the
outsider and the shining it's more of a
mind torn against itself in the case of
the outsider that's true of ben
mendelsohn's ralph anderson who can't
trust what he's seeing due to the
fantastical nature of the images and the
trauma he's experiencing from losing his
son and cynthia revo's holly gibney has
a beautiful mind but can she manage to
harness its power in time to nab this
thing causing rampant destruction all
over many towns the shining features a
jack torrance who already has a screw
loose and then he gets to the hotel it's
not a good combination if you're a fan
of stability the grounds themselves can
turn into villains with accommodations
this haunted and one quickly realizes
that it's impossible to tell what's in
our imagination and what's actually
playing out before our eyes plus when
your kid is clairvoyant and is seeing a
bunch of wacko stuff riding around in
the hallways it adds more goosebumps to
the viewer's arm and maybe i'm starting
to see some separation between the
shining and everything else what do we
think every time we watch a haunted
house movie move
like i get it you sunk a lot of money
into this place it's a family heirloom
whatever start fresh sands ghosts get
out of the house and three of our four
top stephen king properties all focus on
a town that's being terrorized maybe
it's a few counties in the outside or
crossing a state line even but the point
remains if you're not like pennywise get
out of dairy you're not a fan of
vampires pack your bags and head down
san diego way but packing up and
starting over ain't so easy when the
devil might have already infiltrated
your mind the brilliance of 1997's the
shining is that jack could become
unhinged anywhere the hotel just
happened to be next in his path and i'll
also add that i always had a great time
with clowns as a kid the circus certain
fast food purveyors birthday parties i
really liked clowns but now as an adult
who frequently does stand up on the road
i've stayed in lots of hotels where it
feels like i don't know if something's
going on i've never stayed in room 237
i'll take room 1408 before i take a
shower with that thing in the shining
bathroom hell bates motel has
competitive rates and a continental
breakfast i've long since stopped
worrying about when pennywise is coming
back nowadays vampires just want to fall
in love and as mysterious as the
outsider is it simply can't match the
psychological gymnastics that the
shining has done to virtually every
traveler at one point or another the
shining gets the point here wins the
wild card round and thus takes the match
and the crowd is chanting red rum as
they storm the court look this was an
impossible task today choosing the best
stephen king tv property it's probably
easier to caretake a haunted hotel than
to render a final winner in this realm
but hopefully we all got to celebrate
the mighty king legacy maybe some of you
folks found a new show or two that you
need to check out me i never heard of
lacey's story until our expert
researcher mark hoffmeyer took a break
from watching deep blue sea again to
tell me about it and it's fantastic
julianne moore dane dehaan clive owen
are you kidding me it's a plus stuff
deep blue sea is pretty good and now
it's your turn dear viewer what's your
favorite stephen king tv project of all
time hit me up on social media with your
take at mark ellis live and stay tuned
to rotten tomatoes for all the latest in
the world of tv movies and everything in
between thanks for watching versus i'm
mark ellis and no i will not come play
with you i will take a balloon
[Applause]
[Music]
you